Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Anochecer de verano en la playa.
Una pareja está sentada
sobre la arena tibia
mirando cómo se eleva
la luna sobre el mar.
En un arranque romántico, una le dice
a la otra: te regalo la luna.
No sé Uds., pero si paso por ahí,
me paro y en tono firme le digo:
Eso no es posible.
El tratado sobre los principios que rige
la actividad de los estados
en el uso y exploración
del espacio ultraterrestre,
incluso la luna y otros
cuerpos celestes, de 1967,
prohibirle la expropiación de la luna.
Y surge en el derecho civil
que nadie puede regalar
algo que no le pertenece.
(Risas)
No las jodo más, hasta luego.
(Aplausos)
Soy abogado espacial. Eso existe.
Me dedico a pensar marcos legales
para prevenir y resolver
conflictos en el espacio.
Pero ¿hay leyes en el espacio?
¿Por qué debería preocuparme
lo que pase allá arriba?
Nuestras vidas dependen del espacio
mucho más de lo que creemos.
Sin satélites no podríamos
ver la tele, mandar un mail,
realizar una transacción bancaria,
buscar una calle en el GPS
y lo peor de todo, no podríamos
encontrar un match en Tinder.
(Risas)
A diferencia de lo que solemos pensar
hoy el espacio
es un ambiente congestionado,
un área en disputa
y altamente conflictiva.
Y donde hay conflictos,
ya sabemos, hay abogados.
(Risas)
Pero ¿qué está pasando
ahora mismo en el espacio?
Supongamos que
en este momento todos nosotros
estamos dentro de una gran nave espacial
y nos proponemos
recorrer el sistema solar.
Despegamos,
todo va bien, hasta que aparece
el primer problema:
¿Dónde empieza el espacio?
¿Cuál es la frontera
hacia arriba de los países?
No existe consenso internacional sobre eso.
Y es difícil de lograrlo, porque
cuando establecés una frontera
le ponés un límite a tu jurisdicción.
Por ejemplo, si el límite de EE.UU.
es de 300 km sobre el nivel del mar,
en el kilómetro 301 China o Rusia
podrían colocar satélites espías.
Seguimos en la nave.
Tenemos una velocidad promedio
de 27 000 km/h.
Cuando de pronto nos choca de costado
un satélite ruso fuera de servicio,
que nos abolla un panel solar
y nos rompe la antena.
¿Quién es responsable?
¿Cómo se demuestra la culpa en el espacio?
¿Existe seguro contra todo riesgo?
(Risas)
Esto no es nada extraordinario.
De hecho, es cada vez más frecuente
porque nadie se hace cargo
de la chatarra espacial.
Hoy en día, el 94 % de los objetos
en el espacio son basura.
Es como si el 94 % de los autos
que vemos en la calle
fuera chatarra abandonada.
Incluso peor,
porque esa chatarra
se mueve a 27 000 km/h.
Pero seguimos nuestro viaje por el cosmos.
Luego de unos meses
paramos en un asteroide
a estirar las piernas
y cargar agua para el mate.
Ahí descubrimos que contiene
metales pesados como oro y platino,
así que decidimos llevarnos un souvenir.
Está establecido que la luna
y los demás cuerpos celestes
son patrimonio de la humanidad y
no le pertenecen a ningún país o empresa.
Pero ¿qué pasa por ejemplo
con los minerales o el agua
extraído de los asteroides?
¿Está permitida la minería de asteroides?
Parece ciencia ficción pero no lo es.
De hecho, EE.UU. y Luxemburgo
ya sancionaron leyes que regulan
la explotación de recursos
naturales en el espacio.
Incluso Argentina tiene un proyecto
de ley similar en el Congreso.
Se nos acaba el combustible,
así que regresamos a casa.
Pero al poco tiempo recibimos una factura
por el estacionamiento en el asteroide.
Suena raro, pero esto ocurrió.
En el año 2001, cuando una sonda
de la NASA llamada NEAR
aterrizó en el asteroide Eros.
Un año después la NASA recibió una factura
por el estacionamiento
de la sonda en el asteroide
con una tarifa de USD 20 por día.
La factura y la intimación al cobro
provenían de un tal Gregory Nemitz
que se decía el propietario del asteroide
basado en derechos otorgados
por la Constitución de los EE.UU.
Obviamente, la NASA
respondió de forma negativa.
Pero Nemitz insistió y decidió llevar
el caso a la justicia.
Se necesitaron tres años
y la intervención de dos tribunales
para rechazar definitivamente la demanda.
Hay un tema del que no les hablé
y me preocupa especialmente.
La militarización del espacio.
Desde la década del 60
existe presencia militar
en las distintas órbitas de la Tierra.
Pero ahora estamos frente
a una nueva amenaza:
Que el mismo espacio se convierta
en un nuevo campo de batalla.
En los últimos años
las potencias intensificaron
su actividad militar en el espacio,
donde ensayaron distintas armas
como misiles que destruyen satélites,
o satélites que chocan unos contra otros.
Lo que se llama "kinetic kill"
o "muerte por movimiento".
A partir de esto EE.UU. decidió crear
para fines del 2019
una nueva fuerza armada en el espacio
llamada Space Force.
Lo que hasta ahora veíamos en las películas
hoy comienza a ser realidad.
Estamos en el amanecer
de una nueva era espacial.
Y nos proponemos ser
una especie multiplanetaria.
Las actividades espaciales
han generado innumerables beneficios.
Pero también enormes desafíos.
Desechos espaciales,
minería de asteroides,
privatización del espacio,
turistas en órbita,
bases permanentes en la luna,
colonización de Marte,
y la militarización del espacio.
Esos son algunos de los temas que
debemos resolver los abogados espaciales.
Pero se abren nuevos interrogantes.
¿Cómo debemos gobernar
el espacio en el futuro?
¿El espacio es un lugar donde
debemos competir o cooperar?
El espacio es una
fuente infinita de sueños.
Y allí se encuentra el futuro colectivo
de la humanidad.
Por eso, para mí, el gran desafío
del derecho espacial
está en garantizar un enfoque
racional y responsable
en el uso del espacio en beneficio
de toda la humanidad,
para no cometer en el espacio
los mismos errores
que cometimos en la tierra.
Pero principalmente para
mantener vivos esos sueños.
(Aplausos)
Igual, si me ven en la playa
quédense tranquilos
que no los voy a demandar.
Si es necesario,
yo también regalo la luna.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)